valentina what is up how we doing hi dr
john
thank you for taking my call i'm a big
fan thank you so much i'm a fan of yours
how can i help thanks well um
i live in a sexist marriage for over
nine years
and i don't know what to do um
i'm i've gained weight i'm a little
depressed
i i don't know what to do so sexless
marriage up it's been cycles for nine
years or y'all been married for nine
years and it's evolved into this
we we've been there for nine years and
since we got married
it's his libido or his desire has
decreased
he has been tested his testosterone is
low
then we just recently tested and it's
high now it's normal
but his desire isn't there okay and
it's hard for a woman to have um
a higher desire or i guess maybe
i don't know if i'm the only woman that
has this in america
but my husband has like zero desires we
have
intimacy once every two months once
every
month once every three months it's very
difficult
yeah so you posed several questions
there so number one
no actually it's it's a big secret and
it's a secret that weighs on the hearts
of women
millions of women across the country it
weighs in the hearts and backs of
millions of men
across the country is this idea of
expected libido
guys are the the cultural narrative is
that guys are just these sex crave
lunatics that are always wanting to do
it and that's all they ever think about
and wives are prepped for this well you
know he's just gonna and then they get
to this marriage with a set of mixed
matched
expectations and then things just go
awry
so out of just sheer curiosity what are
the things you've tried over the last
nine years
well um i've tried role-playing um
i've bought very sexy lingerie
um even though i'm not into porn
and he was very important when we were
dating and then
suddenly it just he took up all the porn
out of that out of the house and we were
dating our sex type was awesome
when we were dating and then i've even
suggested if you want if that stimulates
you
if you want to watch porn we can try
what they're doing and
it just i don't know we've even tried to
set up a schedule you know to see
if you know such days we can role play
and
you know we'll meet me at a bar we'll go
to a hotel nothing
and so yeah you've gotten to the point
where you're trying to force feed it in
there
um what yeah or just you've gotten to a
point where you're trying to make it
happen
what does he say
very ashamed and late we had a huge
fight
um a couple days ago
i'm sorry i'm getting emotional no of
course and um he just said that i have
to deal with it
and it's difficult yeah absolutely
we've i've you know we are we've been
trying to have a baby but like i told
him we need to try
if we're trying to have a baby we
haven't been able to conceive in five
years but
we both need to do our part
right so i i just feel lost i feel very
lonely
yeah i feel very alone abandoned
emotionally i've
never ever cheated on my husband i've
never wanted to do that and i don't
want to do that ever i'm a christian
woman
i love my husband i don't know what to
do
and i sank into a little bit of
depression i feel
i gained 20 pounds because of it
i don't know what to do so number one i
want to applaud you for reaching out and
being vulnerable okay
thank you thank you for honoring me with
your trust there okay
thank you the second thing is is trite
as this sounds
this is more than likely not a valentina
issue
okay and i want you to
i mean high praise to you for giving it
all you had
and for really trying to work through if
it was situational based if it was
desire based if it was
i'll do fantasy based whatever it
happens to be
it sounds like you've put in the effort
and the love
and the care and you've tried to really
do your part there and i and i
i salute you okay i want you to hear
that
um the other side of you just got to
deal with it that's not an acceptable
answer to me
and so were this clear this call is hard
for me
is i can't talk to him right
and so my guess is well i don't even
wanna
to speculate there's so much that leads
to low
libido there is so much that leads to
um the potential for sexless marriages
and it can be everything from
like you said shame that's all it's
relational based all the way back from
childhood
there could be this moment when you
became girlfriend you became wife and
he's got a picture of wife which is
really just an elevated mother and
guys don't like to sleep with their
mothers and so it could be this big
psychological quagmire
it could be something not testosterone
related but something
other um more medically biological
related
it could be that he is finding himself
attracted to
um men and not women it could be a
hundred thousand different things
and we've discussed that you know are
you homosexual do you like men
um he says no he's not attracted to men
um he's not an uh sex uh um a drug
addict at all
right he's not into drugs he's not
cheating i've looked
and nothing here's the deal here's the
deal listen listen
listen this is gonna be hard to hear but
he is not
a puzzle to be solved okay
and he's not a problem to be fixed
he's a person to be with and what i'm
guessing is the amount of shame he is
walking through the world
right now is extraordinary
and people who are feeling shame think
of a backpack full of cinder blocks and
people who are carrying that around
say things that they don't mean they get
frustrated at the world just because
their knees hurt just taking simple
steps and so statements like you just
gotta deal with it
that's not a statement of somebody who
loves and cares and desires somebody
that's a statement of somebody who's
hurting
okay yeah and so he's had an erection
problem
so he has ed right he does have that but
and the root of so much of that can be
psychological and physical and
trauma it can be so much have you guys
gone to see a counselor has he going to
see somebody
psychologically we have um
the first year of the marriage because
from the day that we got married we had
intimacy that day and then five months
later
we did it and i kept you know
um pursuing him and nothing so i did go
to a counselor by myself
at first he did go for one or two
sessions but then he didn't want to
he was too ashamed to talk there you go
to a woman
about the situation about the fact that
he can't get an erection
and it's difficult for men than for
women that's what he said
well that's just again it's not that's
just guys him trying to
package this in a way that he can wake
up every morning because the the
the shame is pretty overwhelming um okay
so he's got to
this is not a you know i think so this
is a have to
he has to go see somebody and talk about
the things that are
wound up in his heart and soul and
here's the thing
you can't make him do that the more you
try to control and pressure and push
that's more bricks and more rocks of
shame in the backpack that he's already
fallen over from right what you can do
is you can go see somebody
to deal with your frustration and your
heartache
and you can model for him what
somebody's standing a little bit taller
and a little bit taller and a little bit
taller looks like
okay okay i want to
i'm telling you this but i'm also
telling anybody watching this anybody
listening to this
life is too short to live in a sexless
marriage life is too short to live
with bad sex with people who don't talk
to one another
people who don't communicate people put
up for a decade with things that they
don't like they're not comfortable with
things that they wish their partner was
doing just because they they
carry these secrets around they don't
have hard conversations with one another
and so we will go two years five years
10 years 20 years
without having hard conversations and
and suddenly man we find ourselves
sitting on a couch again two inches
apart from one another and
2 000 miles away we're in different
planets
right and life is too short for that i'm
speaking the choir here i know that
the only person this is gonna be hard to
hear the only person
valentina that you can deal with right
now the only person that you can
you can you can change
is you you can control your thoughts
and your actions and the things that he
says
the things that he doesn't respond to a
decade
of trying to become his muse is warning
your soul out
it's heavy and it's exhausting and
i want you to walk with a professional
counselor for a season
to make sure that that doesn't become
your shame that you're carrying
that somehow your value is diminished
because you couldn't accomplish this
thing in somebody else
you have more value than that you've got
more integrity than that
and you are worth more than that and i
want you to model for him
what getting well looks like what being
whole looks like
i'm not concerned the fact that he's got
libido issues that happens
i'm concerned that he doesn't care
enough about you
to go to the ends of the earth to try to
be whole and well
in men listening to this men watching
this there is not an excuse
to not be honest with a doctor there is
not an excuse
to not go see a counselor and say help
me i am drowning
the person that i love more than
anything else in the world
because of crap that i'm carrying that
happened to me when i was a kid there's
no shame in not being able
to put down your own bricks guys i'm
telling you from a dude that struggled
with it it's
hard it is hard but when we commit to
somebody for the rest of their life and
we tell them that we love them
we have an obligation to go to the ends
of the earth
the ends of the earth that means going
to have an awkward check at the doctor
that means sitting down with a therapist
male or female i don't care
and saying here's what happened to me
when i was a kid here's what i see when
i look in the mirror
here's what a wife
meant to me growing up and all of a
sudden i can't be
i was wildly in love passionately in
love while dating
recklessly erotic when we were dating
and
now that we're married it's i lost it um
the whole world transmission the whole
thing changed i'm terrified of being a
dad whatever the thing is
the combination of medical psychological
guys go
see somebody and this is not just about
sex this is about
depression this is about anxiety this is
about guys who are
worried about being good parents i don't
care what your issue is guys get over it
the world needs us to step up and start
feeling the world needs us to step up
and start being vulnerable
the world needs us to step up and start
being with people
not over them connected to them not in
charge of them
and so i'm i'm i'm i'm begging you guys
go talk to somebody that will hear you
and that will love you